la série noire continue pour plaisir les
jaune et noir ont concédé une quatrième
défaite de suite en nationale 3 les
plaisirs oies se sont inclinés contre
haguenau sur le score de 35 à 31 ce
dimanche à domicile les plaisirs a mené
pourtant de trois buts à la fin de la
première période beaucoup d'amertume
parce que on mène à plusieurs reprises
de quatre buts et
on remet systématiquement l'adversaire
en selle en ayant bien trop d'échecs
passes ratées tirs manqués sur des
solutions où l'adversaire n'a pas
forcément provoquer notre note
défaillance après bon l'adversaire s'est
battu jusqu'au bout non qui mérite sa
victoire ça va là le débat mais on donne
beaucoup trop de cartouches à notre
adversaire
cette défaite face à un adversaire
direct dans la course au maintien aura
peut-être de lourdes conséquences pour
la suite du championnat
les plaisirs sont actuellement lanterne
rouge de la poule avec seulement deux
victoires depuis le début de la saison à
venir cette boulot déjà c'est repartir à
l'entraînement
costaud vaillant et puis qu'on retrouve
nos valeurs parce que là je trouve qu'on
perd vraiment notre handball et à cette
mentalité qu'on avait et dernière qui
nous a permis d'atteindre les barrages
pour la nationale 2 prochain match pour
plaisir le dimanche 27 janvier toujours
à domicile face à un autre concurrent
direct pour le maintien thionville
moselle handball l'avant dernier du
championnat
victoire impérative pour continuer à
croire au maintien en fin de saison